hi everyone welcome to the homeroom live
stream sal here from khan academy uh we
have a very exciting guest today
margaret spellings former secretary of
education of the united states and ceo
of texas 2036
but before we get to that i will give my
standard announcements first of all a
reminder that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization we can only
exist through philanthropic donations so
if you're in a position to do so please
think about going to khan academy.org
donate
i also want to give a special shout out
to several corporations that have
stepped up uh when they appreciated how
many people were leaning on khan academy
during the covet crisis and continue to
lean on khan academy and that we were
already running at a deficit and our
costs were going up so special thanks to
bank of america google.org att fastly
novartis and the many other supporters
of khan academy
but we still have a gap especially as we
go into 2021 so as much help as you can
provide is very much appreciated also
want to remind everyone that you can get
a version of this live stream wherever
you get your podcast homeroom with sal
the podcast
so with that i'm excited to introduce
secretary spellings
hi sal thanks for everything you do
no well thanks thanks for for joining us
uh obviously it's a it's a day where
there's a lot of going on in the world
but it looks like the election results
are kind of in a paused mode so maybe
maybe it is a good time for us to chat
about something else yeah
exactly about something else so
there's a ton to talk about and i want
to encourage everyone watching to put
any questions you have for secretary
spellings or myself
on the message boards we have team
members who will surface them and i'll
try to get to as many as possible
but margaret you know there's i guess
two things i'd love to talk about well
first of all
explain to all of us what texas
what texas 2036 is
2036 is the bicentennial of texas our
200th birthday and we use that kind of
as a as a hook
to to try to get people to think about
the future uh what we're trying to do is
put what i call the sensible center
together to think long term about the
most important issues that confront our
state and of course those are education
and health natural resources
infrastructure the way our government
performs justice and safety issues
and we're trying to corral people to
focus on the future to think big to
think long term and to use tons and tons
of data the facts to inform our work
and is this is this is like a is this
part of is it kind of spawned by the
government or is it a separate kind of
industry not for profit
it's an it's a not-for-profit
organization really created by the
business community it's a who's who of
business and civic leaders from around
our state who want us to get out of the
tyranny of the urgent
uh and think long term about what our
state will need you know we know texas
like california nevada the west where we
where we uh operate uh is big and
growing and getting more diverse by the
day we're getting older we're getting
younger we have a great hand to play
with human capital as our number one
asset but we have to do a lot of things
right to make sure that we fulfill uh
them and leverage the the possibility
that we have with this vast number of
talented people we have in our state
and what you know paint a picture for us
what what does texas 2036 look like uh
if if y'all are successful
well we will have invested uh in
education and health we sadly lead the
nation in the number of uninsured uh
adults and children we have the health
outcomes to to show for it we are dead
last on things like maternal mortality
and diabetes and obesity and things like
that when it comes to health indicators
where we were once in the mid 30s on our
national education report card and
reading we have fallen to the low 40s
on the nape and reading and so we have
work to do and you know it's going to
take vigilance and attention by the
business community it's going to take
resources but it's going to take really
all of us understanding that these are
the priorities for our state
and for our nation
and we have to attend to them in the
short term and over the long haul
rome wasn't built in the day
absolutely
and and putting your education hat on
which is really you know part of
education 2036 and obviously your
experiences as secretary of education
you know whoever is the next
administration obviously we've had a
beyond the healthcare crisis the
economic crisis we've had an education
crisis because of distance learning and
covid
one could argue we already had an
education crisis even before kovid
if you were advising whoever is going to
be secretary of education come january
what would you encourage them to focus
on and and how to approach it
well one of the things i think is so
critical and you've just said it saul is
that you know our students have really
lost ground and in some cases we've lost
the kids i mean literally our enrollment
in texas is down six percent that's
those numbers hold up across the country
we have probably two to four million
students who were enrolled last year and
and aren't this year mostly in the early
grades and pre-k programs and the like
for those students that are uh enrolled
and learning uh we know that it's not as
productive as it once was uh obviously
with an inability often to meet
face-to-face and engage with teachers
and peers
and so we really have to confront
learning loss we cannot afford to lose
this generation of kids
and they are way behind
overall especially our poor and minority
students those students for whom covet
has revealed really an incredible amount
of inequity and so what i would do if i
were advising uh the the next president
is to say and and you're tailor-made for
this all you know we've got to think
about how are we going to get our
students caught up and how are we going
to use tutoring and one-on-one coaching
and
other interventions research based
practices to get those kids caught up
secondly i would say we have to have
broadband ubiquitous broadband and
devices everywhere period and we need a
national plan to do that obviously
states are
important in those discussions so those
are two things i would do right
away and actually i'll put the i'd also
love you to advise us because you know
your first point actually it touches on
both points but on that first point
about ways do you how do you fill in
folks gaps do the necessary remediation
so that this year's damage doesn't last
you know that's what we work on a lot
here at khan academy but i'll be very
open you know it's when i think about
interfacing at kind of a governmental
level especially the federal government
it feels very intimidating how do you
get these two worlds to kind of
work together do you think there are
opportunities there
i sure do you know there are there are
platforms like uh americorps and city
year and programs like that that could
be
built out to engage a workforce if you
will that could be engaged in this
tutoring and coaching you know we know
here's the problem kids have have lost
ground
and second we know we need to intervene
with them in safe ways well how do we do
that well it's going to be one-on-one
engagement
often online sometimes in person can be
in person we could do that safely
potentially how do we get them trained
and with research-based practices how do
we identify the kids that need help the
most and how do we use platforms like
americorps and others to you know set
sail and and join hands on this on this
uh
issue you know i think people whether
they're retired people or university
students people want to help our
students catch up
and so you're kind of imagining a world
where americorps or maybe even a broader
kind of coalition of volunteers are
actually going in there and providing
the one-on-one help that a lot of kids
are going to arguably always needed but
need even more now
exactly and i and i think we have
existing platforms both at the state and
federal level that can be deployed to do
that we can pay some of these people
maybe there are some that are volunteers
what we know for sure is that these
individuals will need skills and
training uh at a sophisticated level uh
to help kids get caught up obviously you
know it's easier to do and with younger
children then if you're trying to help
kids get caught up in calculus you have
to know something about calculus
like you saw
no no i i i i absolutely you know it's
interesting because obviously khan
academy is one layer where people can
get practice at their own time and pace
and fill in those gaps uh and you know
one idea that your your last comment
just kind of triggered in my mind is
maybe working with a lot of these groups
so that they can be kind of a a force
that engages a lot of these students on
platforms like khan academy but also the
opportunity to do
small group or one-on-one tutoring
there's a separate not-for-profit that
we've just spawned up that i've just
spawned up it's separate from khan
academy called schoolhouse.world which
is focused on how do we pair students
for free uh with live tutoring uh so i'd
love to talk to you
offline about how all of these different
pieces uh can can fit together on the
digital divide which is kind of your
second big point which i couldn't agree
with more
what do you think well well first
question
why don't you think this was part of you
know maybe the first few rounds of
stimulus it feels like a no-brainer to
me you know for 10 or 20 billion dollars
out of a trillion or two
you could maybe solve this problem um
and do you think this is you have hopes
that it will happen in the next few
rounds of stimulus
you know it's it's a complicated problem
every state is different their provider
community the private sector community
is different in each state uh whether
they have attacked this through some
sort of a central planning process or a
hub
that varies all over the country so i
know that we in texas are one of just
six states that don't have a plan which
limits our ability to draw down federal
resources
but when i ask why is that it's because
we're big we have a multitude of
providers we have you know the
not the bottom of the grand canyon but
the rio grande valley i mean very very
remote places and then of course what we
know for sure and you know this uh is
that in urban america this is an
affordability issue uh it's not that the
infrastructure doesn't exist it's that
folks
can't afford the hundreds of dollars
often it is for those high-speed
connections
and and how would you recommend we we
can solve this is this something that
does get solved at the federal
government level you put in a stimulus
program or something else or is it is
this more of a state level issue
i think it's going to have to be a
combination of both i mean some federal
policies some some freeing up
of options for states but states are
fundamentally going to have to attack it
you know obviously we need additional
resources from the federal government we
we in the states cannot print money for
these sorts of things like they can but
if we're going to address it quickly uh
it'll need to be a partnership
and and as we go through this crisis
obviously a lot of sub-optimal things
you know we've talked about several of
them a lot of kids might fall further
behind they've been disengaged do you
see any potential silver linings from
what we're going through right now or or
reasons for hope
yeah you know i i used that same phrase
and arne duncan corrected me the other
day and said these are not silver
linings they're hard lessons and and i
and i agree with that but but i do think
there are some some takeaways
uh that that uh and some learnings from
this one is
i think parents are have a better
understanding of where their students
are
uh you know it's one thing to get a a
report card home in the backpack and
it's a whole other thing to see your
child
working and struggling and maybe not
reading on grade level or uh with the
you know needed math skills or whatever
so i think parents have some insights
they didn't before
uh secondly i think you know we've made
a little much more progress in
technology
uh learning and and having our teachers
yes struggle with it but make progress
and understand how we could
better maximize this tool
uh third i think we're learning and
seeing that it can be a tool where
customization and embedded assessment
mod progress monitoring can be you know
standard uh operating procedure
uh so i think there are some things
we're also learning that our human
capital can be deployed in more
efficient smarter ways
maybe we need to have the world's best
lecturer
doing the teaching
remotely while you know others are doing
coaching and one-on-one
meetings with parents and families and
students and the likes so i think we are
learning some things we're seeing a
proliferation of innovation and problem
solving around the country and one thing
i do think is missing that i wish we
would would do is engage our
universities to go
uh establish a research agenda so that
at the end of the day at the end of this
big experiment we've learned some things
about what worked and what didn't
i love that last idea because yeah
there's always you know universities
always looking for things to research
and we have a massive experiment going
on right now
that seems worth worth studying so we're
getting a lot of questions in from a
social media from youtube park pal
is asking what's it like being secretary
of education
what do secretaries of education do
uh and yeah that's a i mean i'll just
add to that question one question yeah
we imagine you know in other countries
would call it a minister of education
what is the role how is it special in
the united states especially
well you know
it's an important platform and i think
uh and you know i'll leave to the
audience uh how well it's been maximized
in this recent past but you know if i
were the secretary of education i would
be gathering experts
from all of these fields mental health
uh technology
disease control space utilization i
never called anybody from the white
house or from the us department of
education and say i need your help where
they didn't come running and so i think
it can be a convener of expertise a
proliferator of information and practice
it can be a great listening agency as
and department as people are struggling
with and learning from uh what happens
so to use that bully pulpit in really
muscular ways is is a big part of the
job
secondly it can be an advocate
for resources both within the
administration and in the congress and
a translator of what's happening
around the country and and a solution
provider uh so that the congress can um
can act and you know i i think we could
do a better job of doing that too
especially on things like broadband you
know what are the consequences for not
having broadband in our schools both in
terms of learning loss but in terms of
of health care and and a lack of
economic connectedness and the like so
it's basically an information
uh proliferator
a listener and a gatherer of expertise
on the policy level and then secondly
and importantly especially in higher
education certainly in k-12-2 it is a
distributor of needed resources
especially around issues of equity title
one schools uh financially uh needy
students in higher education and the
like
on that last on that kind of policy
budgetary front where do you see the
biggest levers you know if you were if
you were advising the next president
where would you try to make sure you see
extra investment
well i think you know one of the things
of course you would expect me to say
this as a as a
strong advocate for assessment and
measurement and transparency
that no child left behind
started and that was affirmed by the
every student succeeds act and that is
that we have to you know we will not
solve issues of equity if we bury our
heads in the sand and stop caring enough
to find out as i like to say so how do
we think about uh measurement and
accountability and testing in this era
what's appropriate how do we do it how
do we collect data how do we
still have that accountability you know
we taxpayers are paying a big load uh
for educating our students and yes these
are our challenging times but but how
might we think about those issues going
forward i'm a big what gets measured
gets done kind of person
and i i think that's a major issue
before policy makers and educators now
and how do we thread that needle because
it makes tons of sense you know anytime
someone says you know it's very popular
to beat up standardized assessment and i
always say would you prefer
non-standardized assessment would you
prefer no assessment
uh because uh you know
you need it
right but but
yeah maybe some people would agree with
that but you know but it does seem like
it's an interesting question of how it
is used or how it is is perceived you
know there's a lot of debate right now
at the college admissions level around
schools going testing optional and maybe
out of necessity because of covid but
some you know the university of
california system just like you know
literally said we will not consider
acts or sats
how do you think this is going to evolve
and and where do you think it should
evolve too
well what we know is that no system is
perfect and as you say you know a lot of
higher ed institutions are test optional
well
in my view it's just a matter of time uh
before things that are less standardized
less validated uh more subjective
come into question about fairness
discrimination uh and whatnot so uh i
like to think that you know what we need
is a full full and complete picture
of which standardized measurement is a
part
and certainly that's that's true in k-12
education as well where i think we are
getting and this is what technology will
bring us is embedded progress monitoring
along the way that gives teachers
real-time information so that they can
tailor their their instruction they can
intervene uh with students you know
along the way one of the things that was
a i guess a flaw although you know the
industry was where it where it was uh
you know back in those days you know
that the teachers didn't see the value
in assessment because it took too long
to get any information to them that was
useful
and so i think technology will help us
solve those gaps course correct and
it'll be better for kids it'll be better
for teachers and i hope that you know
the this high stakes notion will will
die down you know it's real high stakes
for students to lose as much educational
ground as they're losing now
and explain the term progress monitoring
a little bit more it's a term for those
who are in education it's a term that's
very fashionable these days what does it
mean to you
it means that you're checking in on
students in a regular way and course
correcting along the way so just like
you when you know when i was in school
back in the dark ages you know you had
your weekly spelling check or your
weekly pop quiz or you know so it's it's
a regular assessment uh low stakes
embedded often online that gives
teachers and students information about
where they are
yeah the way we imagine it is
as you mentioned it could be on a paper
base it doesn't need technology but you
know like on something like khan academy
every interaction
is not just practice it's also an
assessment you can log it and we give
the reports to teachers and if they can
look at that in real time
they can make the appropriate
interventions and and uh do that type of
thing and to your point in that type of
a world you don't have to have that you
know you got one shot at this student
and it you know this is going to be your
grade for the term depending on how you
do if you haven't done so well the first
go keep working on it and not a big deal
exactly exactly that's the other thing
that i think is going to be of silver
lining out of this is you know we are
learning and we already knew this but
you know we'll come to expect that you
know education is more a la carte that
some students are going to master
something in three months some it will
take 13 months but that that this
customization because of the embedded
progress monitoring and because the use
of technology coupled with great
educators will really uh change this
model i hope
so you know we talked a lot about a 2036
from a texas lens but i'll stay indexed
on that year since that's a lot of focus
of your life
how do you think especially the
education world you know
we talked a little bit about how texas
might be different in 2036 but how do
you think education
needs to be different or how do you
think it will be different if we go fast
forward 15 or 16 years you know i think
we have to start
thinking more seriously about how we use
time
different from now you know the academic
year has been blown up the academic
calendar has been blown up and so how do
we
use our time in ways that are uh more a
la carte
my word uh and and we have things like
stackable credentials and badging and
proof of mastery along a continuum uh
and you just put that in your in your
portfolio or your backpack or whatever
uh so that you're evidencing you're
learning along the way i think one thing
that i've seen and this is certainly
happening in higher education and
certainly in the employer community you
know brand is starting to matter much
less you know the name of the
institution on the top of your diploma
matters less now than you know can you
code can you think critically can you
write can you
you know this that and the other thing
and i think we
in education and in organizations like
yourself are going to have to help
translate does this person have a skill
does this person have this knowledge
no you're absolutely i mean i i i also
share that dream
that you know in the next five 10 15
years
pathways are not based on seat time
there's alternative pathways they're
based on competency um and you can kind
of cluj together your own experience and
they can they can directly um have have
pathways to whatever folks want you know
just in the remaining time we have we
have a lot of educators watching this we
have a lot of parents we have a lot of
students any you know kind of thoughts
uh that you any advice you would have
for them one is they're trying to
navigate their their own or their
children's education through covid and
then think about the future broadly
well i do think there's there's no harm
whether you're a policymaker in a state
legislature or or a mom or dad with a
student or or a teacher understanding
you know how are we aligning our
performance with our use of resources
and what i like to say is we got to put
our money where our mouths are you know
we say it's important to to close the
achievement gap and to make sure that
all students reach a particular level
that was the whole you know genius if
you will behind no child left behind and
having those higher expectations for all
of our students but we also have to
resource
uh that issue like like we
were real
and so we need to be looking at well how
do we deploy technology how do we deploy
teachers i mean our very best teachers
working in our most challenging settings
do we have the right curriculum
technology supports interventions to
close the achievement gap so how do we
think about resources coupled with uh
goals and objectives for students and
families and if you haven't
go find out how your school is doing
obviously those will be old data points
from from last school year
but uh you know this school year we
ought to be looking at
not necessarily accountability based on
a test but where are the kids uh you
know how many minutes are are they
learning uh a day you know what are the
outcomes we have to keep our eye on the
ball
and care enough to find out uh as i like
to say as opposed to kind of this
ostrich approach of burying our heads in
the sand and hoping for the best
yeah yeah don't don't be afraid of the
information don't be afraid of the
messenger so to speak
exactly
no well well thank you so much uh
margaret this was you know uh i guess i
really enjoyed this because a lot a lot
of what you said
resonates very strongly
very very strongly with me uh but you
know it it's always great especially in
times of crisis like this to kind of you
know think about how how we could be
doing things and how we can come out of
this in a in a better uh and better
shape than than we maybe we even entered
it so thank you so much don't waste the
crisis as they say
don't waste the crisis
thank you thank you for joining us
thanks al appreciate you
so thanks everyone for for joining today
uh as always or not always but
especially today uh thank you it was a
great conversation with secretary
spellings uh it's always great to talk
to national leaders who um you know i
think are really thinking about the
future in a way that's going to
best serve students and best serve
teachers and and parents and um i i
thanks for joining and you know we got
to stay tuned i'm also keeping track of
what's going on in the election that's
the other interesting thing going on in
everyone's lives right now uh but we
will see you next week so please join us
for the next uh homeroom with style live
stream then
you